[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando yo era niño
soñaba con cohetes y con ser astronauta
veía todos los despegues desde cabo
cañaveral es el lugar mágico con un mar
al lado donde empezaban las misiones
pero
se me quitaron las ganas
exactamente el 28 de enero de 1986
cuando explotó el challenger lo vi en
televisión en vivo
como llore ese día
pensé entonces que era una profesión muy
peligrosa uno tenía riesgo de morir
tampoco podía ser la mujer en maravilla
ese sitio ya estaba ocupado
eso hizo inclinarme hacia mí otra gran
pasión ser cazadora de micro vis
cazadora de virus
suena película de indiana jones
pero en realidad es un trabajo muchísimo
más bonito menos sucio y por mucho menos
sexy
claro
tampoco es que no tenga poco el riesgo
de morir por un virus no
qué alegría les daría a todos
despertarse mañana y descubrir que los
virus desaparecieron por completo
no solo el coronavirus que nos tiene a
todos confinados sino todos
un mundo sin virus
a mí más bien me espanta esa idea
los virus son fascinantes vienen en
diferentes presentaciones tamaños formas
pero qué son los virus
no podemos decir que son microorganismos
no están vivos
edward un microbiólogo inglés decía que
los virus son malas noticias en un
recipiente
en realidad los virus son información
genética empaquetada ellos necesitan dar
esa información genética a otro ser vivo
para así hacer copias de sí mismo y
perpetuarse
los vinos son fascinantes
pero algunos son super jodidos
en 1918 un virus influenza arrasó con
más de 200 millones de personas
para junio de este año el nuevo corona
virus que nos trajo el 2019 ya había
infectado a más de 10 millones de
personas y había matado a medio millón
al año el dengue infecta 400 millones de
personas en el trópico y en el
subtrópico
por semana el hv infecta a más de 6000
mujeres entre los 15 y los 24 años
podríamos hablar y hablar de lo malo que
son los virus de hecho la palabra virus
en latín significa veneno
y que puede ser peor que un veneno
la mayoría de los virólogos y las
biólogas como yo trabajamos con virus
que causan enfermedad que causan daño
hasta el momento se ha identificado
menos de 250 virus que infectan al ser
humano de la bíró esfera todo ese
universo de virus que se predice que
existen 10 con 31 ceros más conocemos
sólo el 0.000 000 1% no conocemos nada
podríamos asignarle a cada estrella que
conocemos en el universo un virus y
tendríamos que repetir eso cien millones
de veces más
para entender lo pequeño que son en un
grano de sal podrían caber 10.000 bits
son la forma de vida más abundante en el
planeta de hecho si un extraterrestre
llegará hoy a visitarnos diría que la
tierra es un planeta viral con un par de
formas de vida extra utilizadas por los
virus para subsistir sin los virus ni
los seres humanos ni el planeta
existiría moriríamos todos
en cuestión de semanas de lo que
conocemos hay más virus buenos que malos
solo en los océanos son la forma de vida
más abundante en una cucharada de mar
podemos encontrar 1500 millones de virus
que peligroso y yo con todo el agua de
mar que me tragado en mi vida
los virus causan ese número 10 23 ceros
infecciones por segundo en el mar son la
mayor causa de muerte en el planeta pero
muerte de otros microorganismos
así lleguen a controlar la biomasa
matando al 20 por ciento de la misma y
el 50 por ciento de las bacterias
oceánicas cada día
con esto el mar se vuelve un gran
almacén de elementos clave como
nutrientes como minerales hierro fósforo
nitrógeno de energía de todo lo
necesario para la vida
los virus orquestan la disponibilidad de
estos elementos
además los virus controlan el clima
modificando los niveles de dióxido de
carbono en la atmósfera nos ponen a
disposición la proteína que consumimos
todos gracias a los virus se produce el
50 por ciento del oxígeno
respiramos oxígeno por los virus la vida
en el planeta existe por los virus
cuando somos adultos
el 8 por ciento de nuestra información
genética es producto de los retrovirus
endógenos son secuencias virales
antiguas que están intercaladas en
nuestro adn
pero un dato super interesante de qué
tan embebidos están los virus en nuestra
vida es que el momento en que el
espermatozoide fecunda al óvulo y se da
las primeras divisiones celulares hasta
llegar a ser un grupo de ocho células
humanos se expresa más del 50%
información viral y humana
somos más virus que humanos
estos virus ancestrales han estado con
nosotros por más de 130 millones de años
de evolución
y para que no se sabe no se sabe cuál es
el propósito estudios indican que al ser
esto un momento tan vulnerable si llega
a haber algún ataque del sistema inmune
del sistema de defensa de la madre
contra ese corpúsculo inicial lo que se
dañe sea la información viral y no la
humana es como un señuelo destruya esos
virus que no es importante y deje miami
humana tranquila
como si fuera poco sabemos que la
mayoría de los seres vivos están
permanentemente colonizadas por una gran
cantidad de virus
ustedes nosotros todos somos en este
momento más microbio que ser humano
esa mega comunidad microbiana llama al
microbioma está compuesta por 1.5 veces
más bacterias que células humanas
pero 150 veces más virus
qué células humanas
estos virus no son virus que nos
enferman ni que nos mandan al
confinamiento ni a guardar el
distanciamiento físico muy por el
contrario son virus que regulan todo ese
microbioma interno los zombies icann
gracias a los virus que se llaman pavos
del griego devora los virus devora
bacterias y así controlan las bacterias
que nos habitan
esta arma secreta nos puede llegar a ser
útil en una crisis de salud actual
y futura la próxima pandemia la
resistencia a los antibióticos
debido al uso indiscriminado que le
hemos dado los seres humanos a los
antibióticos las bacterias han
desarrollado herramientas para
contrarrestarlos se han vuelto
resistentes nos quedará una única arma
los virus
los devora bacterias los virus buenos
de cohetes y astronautas fueron los
sueños de mi niñez desperté y los virus
me abrieron los ojos a un universo más
vasto e interesante que las estrellas
pero infinitamente desconocido
precisamente por eso necesitamos más
cazadores más cazadoras de virus ustedes
sus hijos sus hijas sobrinos sobrinas
no solo para que trabajemos juntos en
pandemias virales como la actual sino
para descubrir y estudiar esa vivo
esfera y aprovecharnos de los virus de
los virus buenos
[Música]